[Music]
Charles Barkley came on the show a
couple of weeks ago and said the NBA is
watered down that talent level guys
developing you know young kids you know
18 19 coming into the NBA here you are
at the end of your career and what
you've seen is the NBA getting better or
getting worse yeah it's a lot of things
that that players need to work on when I
was young I remember working on my head
fake and triple threat passing there's
simple things like guys can make
backdoor passes they can't anticipate
when guys is going back doing making the
pass
golden stays really good at that but
they work at it you know I'm screening
people don't understand how important
the screen is if you tell a young player
you have to make a thousand good screens
cause they're gonna be a thousand
screens available throughout the season
every single screen is important and
these guys don't really understand that
they think you can get away without
setting a good screen well if you do
that you're not going to teammate open
and that possession is gonna hurt you
you know whether you're trying to get
home court advantage you might lose one
game and instead of having home court
advantage now you got a disadvantage and
those type of things are important and
and that goes back to the fundamentals
and guys don't really put importance on
that but how frustrating is it yet a
young team aside from you and Kobe right
got a young team but it's not just our
team as out as throughout the league but
you're but you're with these guys
constantly and you're trying to teach
them basketball right you get you got -
you got it every day tell them what's
important and it in the beginning it was
tough because when you're you know a
young stud
you probably think you're bigger than
what you are then you humble out a
little bit things balance out and then
they start to listen a little bit but um
every day you got to let them know
what's important the small things are so
important because the small things gonna
get you a championship
who do you think the Lakers should draft
I like the kid Thawne maker I guess he's
gonna be all the 76 kid not be
seven-foot oh really coming out of high
school some high school yeah he's
probably not ready yet but
Simmons I hear a lot about Ben Simmons
I've seen him play once I left thee
Sodom yeah about him but he's a point
guard he's a point guard huh what do you
do with D'Angelo Russell well you know
the guy's gotta earn a spot that's why
you have 15 players and Lakers to draft
some body and then training camp will be
a war which would be great because it'll
be competitive and then people have to
her any spot um how would you rate
D'Angelo Russell's rookie season it was
uh it started how slow he was basically
eighteen years old just turned in
nineteen on he was he a young young
young you got kids who were my daughters
his age you know and he started out
exactly how I expect it as a point guard
you know not not ready physically but
it's very strong he posts up a lot of
these NBA gods I've been in the league
for years he was posting up Beverly he
was posting up Westbrook at times he
tried it will Westbrook a little
stronger to him but he was posting up a
lot of these veteran point guards I'm
like wow this kid got heart he takes big
shots he's gonna be a playoff player
he's a playoff player what was your best
moment ever against Kobe best moment
against Kobe it wasn't many wasn't mine
you were considered one of the great
defenders you were you were a lockdown
defender yeah so when you guarded Kobe
Kobe the thing about Kobe is he never he
never broke you know I played against a
lot of other you know all-stars at the
time you know run-ins for MVPs and I was
able to do what I had to do I guess the
majority of them what do you mean he
never broke even if I was to stop him
three possessions for possession he kept
coming back if I was to bump him he he
wanted that that physical play he never
backed down for physical play not once
has he back down for me now it might
have been a couple times where I stopped
him defensively but he continued to come
game after game possession out the
possession there's really hard guarding
him you face Jordan when he was with the
Wizards yeah what was that like Jordan
was great Jordan was physic
you know I remember we played against
each other in the summertime because
he's at the end of his career you're
you're young right is he still talking
he oh he was amazing Jordan he's still
talking still delivering you know he
wasn't as fast but he was a lot of heart
still can make big shots DEA came back
yeah I was 25
yeah he was a about to retire he came
back average 25 to him it was better
Idaho him to Kobe the different players
this it's so different but uh similar
movements is really hard to say it's
like if Jordan is better that is by inch
if Kobe's bet is only by inch I think
it's that close it's very close cuz if
both those guys were in their prime
playing against each other they're both
giving each other 50 you know
Kobe's not gonna stop Jordan and Jordan
is absolutely not gonna stop Kobe
absolutely not he's not gonna stop him
Kobe's not gonna let you stop him
it's impossible it's impossible Mike was
a good defender Mike was great but Kobe
is amazing Jordan cannot stop Kobe know
who's the most unstoppable player you
ever faced most unstoppable yeah me
oh just good sighs yeah there's nothing
you can do it yeah you have a chance
against other people if you have no
chance to get job just because with the
ball up high or what balls up high he's
fundamentally saying he's not gonna
bring it down he can shoot make
free-throws make big shots game one of
the shots you know a great player great
team player yeah yeah they'll total
package when you were in China did you
know how to trash talk in Chinese yeah
China was where you know those guys is a
physical league and they all wanted to
show that hey you're coming over here to
our league I'll check you you know I'm
not afraid of you right exactly they did
that but you know the league is physical
if you're at home you get all the calls
so we go on the road you know you know
that the other team's gonna get the
calls so but Marbury's become a god over
there
yeah Marbury is doing great guy you're
going the airport got Marbury posters
everywhere you know you got the Marbury
shoes you know I got the statue in
Beijing this is great making a lot of
money over there he's doing great
what are you doing next year hmm next
year I think i'ma try to come back with
the Lakers probably yeah nobody's told
you anything
well it's too early to say I'm in no
rush you know I'm older now so I'm
patient what about coaching coaching is
something I want to do one day I didn't
want to be a head coach one day and I
know I learned a lot I have a good time
coaching you know so hopefully one day
I'll be able to you know be a head coach
you know somewhere college at NBA
what's Kobe do Kobe he's a great writer
you know so everybody always asked what
is probably gonna do he said he's a
writer
so he's creative he has a lot of things
on his mind he's gonna be able to he
could do both stories picture right he
can write songs for people you know he
could do so much if you if he puts his
mind to it you never got into a fight
with him and practice we got into some
bumps me a Kobe argued a lot but but not
where it got physical it wasn't like
punching physical but it was physical it
might have been a fight it could have it
could have gotten in it could have
escalated they were both like stubborn
you know he's very stubborn and I am and
in practice he talks and I'm not gonna
let it slide and then before you before
you know it we're right we're throwing
elbows in practice it was nice nice
who's the guy that you who would make
you nervous on the court
tough guy concern concern about what
just a tough guy um nobody really I mean
you don't strike me as somebody who
scares but right back on the court my
guys always talk about Charles Oakley
Charles Oakley scared people right you
didn't mess with Charles Oakley right is
there anybody in the league that you go
I just always poke that people I always
wanted to but I always wanted to get the
bigger guy to maybe you're the guy like
you're like Charles Oakley maybe you
didn't want to mess with rod right maybe
maybe how this the game was I learned
from the Knicks and the Pistons you know
these guys were aggressive so I'm like
okay that's how I have to play with it
when I get to the league they learned
playing that way didn't you play like
yeah yeah you watch the game and then
you go downstairs and you play exactly
how the next play does the malice in the
palace always stay with you I mean I
don't mind talking about it but it's
never with me like every day I wake up
and you know I do my little yoga do my
little um my mellow hippie routine you
know I'm like a hood hippie I guess talk
about the mallas hey let's talk about it
if you learn from it oh right I mean I
taught you a lot of lessons there but
the one lesson that taught me oh what
I've experienced I don't think it taught
me anything but things could change in a
blink of an eye I mean I had TNT
commercials ESPN commercials have my
college during the commercial set my LA
gear campaign ready to come out oh my
god I was doing so many different things
at that time and then all in one day I
was I was gonna be in a run-ins for MVP
you know I just got off defensive play
of the year my average went up seven
points average of 25 I know you know and
that was a it went from at the peak to
one second down
that was that was amazing that was
pretty uh that was pretty amazing
can you reenact could you lie on my
table here and lie there polio throne
you get to punch Paulie oh honey that
was that was I mean how can you be
avoiding something and then in the
second you're involved trying to I did
everything possible to get away from
that you were laying down I was trying
to wait for this thing to get over with
oh my goodness was a man to do hey it's
always it's always great to see you
thank you and I wish you the best and
hopefully I think there's coaching in
your future absolutely I appreciate it
let me coach you a t-shirt do I have to
wear a damn suit
can I wear a hat and t-shirt on the
[ __ ] I'm gonna say well with this new
Commissioner yes with David Stern no
okay so is good person if you you spent
a lot of time with him that's nice yeah
yeah that's nice he's Metta World Peace
you can interact with him directly
download the free meta the official app
from iTunes check out the latest gear
from the pandas friend previews latest
music go to Metta World Peace calm the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience